we're not home to the last Lama cold
peace be with you I'm gonna your host
you're watching the DS show we're at the
mass pikna we got an exciting show for
you
Yolo have you heard about it have you
heard it you know what Yolo stands for
you only live once
is that what it's all about get all the
money get all the fame get everything
you can because that's it you only live
once we're gonna be talking about this
philosophy when we come back here in
addy show don't know anyway
this is the names not Yolo no my name is
definitely your name is imam Suleiman
Suleiman said now many people have no
idea I just been brought up into loop a
lot of these things we're getting a
little bit older right
now when you kick it you hang out with
the young generation you hear these
phrases I mean just recently I just
found out what a selfie is now Yolo
what's this Yolo all about yellow yellow
man this term is one of the devil's
greatest traps one of the greatest
deceptions for Society for mankind and
although it's come up throughout you
know history throughout the ages in
different ways the issue with Yolo is
that essentially it's trying to get
people to think especially the younger
people as they grow up as they start to
think of more crazy ways to express
themselves more crazy ways to live their
lives more ways to rebel against the
rules of you know society the rules of
religion and so the issue of Yolo
essentially comes down to one thing you
only live once you only live once and so
when they talk about Yolo what they
really are trying to say is you only
live once so do whatever you want you
only live once so go ahead and pull in
the kid you go ahead and drink go ahead
and do something crazy go ahead and make
that decision that you are wondering and
hesitating about a few moments earlier
Yolo I'm just gonna do it so usually
some of the youth when they talk about
Yolo they're talking about you know this
is a decision that they got to make so
they're wondering you know should I do
this should I not this is kind of crazy
like you know pee
do this or this is very immoral or maybe
this is something really disgusting but
then they'll think Yolo whatever you
only live once let me do it and so the
problem with this is that this is one of
the misrepresentations of immorality so
one of the problems of this is that it
is one of the misrepresentations of
immorality where Satan tries throughout
history to come up to different
generations in different ways and so
this tactic this new deception of Yolo
that's kind of become a fad and although
you know it dies out and it comes back
up every now and then and people make a
joke out of it it's still a very serious
issue and so one of Satan's traps one of
his tactics to take people away from the
Creator is to make them first a little
doubt in the Creator now in the day of
resurrection doubt that there will be
any accountability for their actions now
if somebody doesn't really think you
know I'm gonna come back on the day of
the judgement I'm gonna come back and be
held accountable there's consequences
for my actions then they tend to kind of
do whatever they want and one of the
greatest things that Satan can achieve
is if he gets somebody to disbelieve in
the day of judgment then he's safe
Satan is safe from this person why this
person will do whatever they want now
this city doesn't have to worry about
this individual because he doesn't
believe in a day of resurrection does
they believe that there is
accountability that the creator did put
us here for a purpose and that everyone
good and evil every major and minor deed
will come back on the day of
resurrection
now when somebody doesn't believe in the
day of resurrection this means they can
do whatever they want they can
disbelieve in God and there are no
consequences they can you know go
throughout all the types of indulgences
and immoralities that they can find in
society and it doesn't matter because
Yolo you only live one
the reality is you live twice and
everything that people are wondering and
trying to kind of fight and challenge in
regards to the struggles and the
temptations in this world especially
with you know the carefree type of
mentality that's what Yolo is really
about the issue regarding that is that
everything in this world no matter how
long you live no matter what type of
pleasure you have its temporary and the
pleasure of the year after his eternal
but first you have to earn it first you
have to get there you have to earn the
mercy of the Creator and the beautiful
thing about stem is no matter what
you've done in the past whether it's
Yolo or something else whether you
believed in yellow and you live short
and all of that you still always have a
chance to go back so that if you do die
and you do repent to the Creator you
still have that chance to come back in
the second resurrection and have that
blissful hereafter I'm Worcester Pilate
Allah says in Surat Annisa
I must repent Allah says in surah 4
verse 77 billion atomic dunya Pauline
say verily the enjoyment and the
pleasure of this world that which people
are you know so y'all know about that's
what people really want to indulge in
it's temporary but in it's very little
well laid out too high you don't even a
top on and the hereafter is greater for
those who have got consciousness those
who really know their boundaries they
know how to live this life and earn the
next life as well and so the problem
with Yolo and a lot of youth really have
to understand this is that Yolo is
making you forget that which is more
important Yolo is making you forget that
which is required and sufficient for you
in order to get to paradise that
beautiful blissful life that we keep
talking about
and so Ola makes a person kind of
heedless of the Creator heedless of the
day of judgement heedless of any
accountability whatsoever and it's a
dangerous play that is affecting a lot
of people at the same time there's a
positive aspect which is that a lot of
the youth are starting to realize you
know what there aren't consequences for
our actions we are here for a purpose we
will be resurrected again we were
resurrected we're going to realize it's
not Yolo anymore it's you only live
twice you will be resurrected to the
Creator you will have that day where you
meet with the creator and the ass of
everything that came previously and so
Yolo is starting to die out with those
who are you know starting to think and
use their intellect we come to deem that
the person the people who aren't blindly
following the custom the cultures around
them who are really thinking pondering
sincere truth seekers are seeing past
one of these major tricks of the Devils
yeah the straight team pipping people
who are upon this yolo philosophy we're
going to be back with more of the Yolo
you only live once actually twice we're
gonna talk about what does this mean we
live twice back here on the D show is
there a purpose to our lives do we
simply exist to make a living
or were we meant for something greater
something more meaningful
I looked everywhere for answers and I
found Islam
I started my journey
have you started yours please subscribe
to the DCO follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show Yolo you only live
once now you talk you said something
about you look twice we'll get to that
in a second but isn't this now the
biggest pimp shakedown I'm calling he's
trying to pimp the people isn't he so
now the man he's trying to pimp the
woman he's like come on honey you only
live once so now he gets her to maybe
lose her chastity right you know the
brother he's trying to hold on to his
morality not going to the insanity and
they're like come on brother let's go to
the nightclub you only live once is this
how it works absolutely this is a
problem with it it's more of them you
know do whatever you want and it really
it's really sad because Yolo is not just
an individual thing it's not like you're
thinking about you know I'm gonna be
resurrected or I'm not gonna be
resurrected it's really very impactful
how you know friends and society affects
the way we think about this and so in
our day and age it's on the rise where a
friend can come up to you easily and
it's so easy to you know to a pawn to a
peer pressure
so anybody will just tell you go ahead
man just let suppose drink let's go to
the club let's go here let's go there
Yolo who cares it's not a big deal and
you're like this is one of the tactics
of the Devils is that they don't just
try to come to you through you know
they're not gonna come to you as the
devil hey I'm the devil yo go go in and
sin no because if you see the devil
you're not gonna be sinning you're gonna
be pretty afraid and so the issue is
that the devil will come to you in all
the ways of your weaknesses he'll make
you you know fall into this Yolo trap
through all of our desires and
weaknesses and everyone has different
strengths and weaknesses and so a lot of
times in our day and age it's all the
you know types of indulgences that are
prohibited that Shaitaan is trying to
come to people through these things and
so he'll come to them maybe through
their weak friends you come to them
through maybe a television show a movie
that maybe they're really attached to
but maybe it's not too appropriate and
so you come in all these different
platforms and
and when they see these things over and
over and over they start to become
desensitized and so this is one of the
problems in our day and age and a lot of
times and we should mention this a lot
of times you know people look at for
example the power of the media in
affecting this kind of Yolo mentality do
whatever you want
you know indulge in your desires be
carefree this is how I was born you know
I can't control myself just let it go
and even you know you notice now and
this is gonna be very controversial to
some people they even with little kids
they're starting to start this kind of
trend of Yolo in different ways and so
you don't like now they have you know
let it go let it go let it go other kids
are singing it and to them you know it
is is it innocence we're not saying that
the kids are assuming anything else but
these words let it go let your neck go
let your carnal desires free it means do
whatever you want this is the pack of
desires and so you start to become a
slave of your desires you're no longer
asleep to the Creator you're no longer
pursuing the path of the creator you're
no longer worshiping the Creator in the
way that he's pleased or in the way that
earns paradise the way that leads to
paradise and you know it's really really
sad because paradise if we just
described it for hours and hours and
hours it wouldn't be sufficient to
describe what there is in paradise the
bliss and the eternity in paradise is
beyond our description as human beings
and you know I personally travel around
and actually talk about paradise and
Hellfire in depth you know sometimes for
2030 hours of just paradise and Hellfire
and some people wondered is there that
much to you know to say about paradise
there's more and the beautiful thing
about paradise is that what God has told
us about it what God has told us about
it is nothing compared to what he has
prepared for us in paradise and so Yolo
starts to become a triangle structure
become a type of indulgence through
every weakness every platform every
movie every TV show it'll try to somehow
desensitize our hearts and when our
hearts become weak we start to fall into
our you know desires we start to pursue
our weaknesses our you know this and
that it's usually through bad friends
and bad
company and so one of the greatest
things we can do as a shield against
viola after first having the you know
the best intentions possible is to kind
of surround herself with good because
when you surround yourself with people
who are better than you people who are
actually thinking no it's not you live
once you will actually live twice you
start to become inspired you start to
become motivated you know what maybe
there is a purpose
maybe there's something I'm failing
maybe I'm too weak maybe I need these
good people around me in order to stay
strong and so the first thing we can do
after setting that good intention is to
have good company and sometimes people
don't like this issue and you know it's
not something that should be
sugar-coated the reality is if you have
a bad friend who's pulling you down into
this mentality you either agree together
that you no longer agree on you live
once that you live twice older you have
to cut them up or cut her off and
realize to yourself that this person is
not going to stand there on the day of
resurrection on the day when you're
resurrected for your second life and say
you know what it was my fault I was a
bad friend you know let me take their
responsibility let me take their sins
no it's each individual for themselves
yeah and so we all have that
responsibility of believing you only
live twice so you will be resurrected
you'll you know come to accountability
you come to meet the Creator one on one
with no barriers no translators no
mediators whatsoever and so this is a
big issue that's you know starting to
become trendy at the same time there are
people starting to realize you know
there are ways to circumvent this
absolutely now someone says look you
know the skeptic is like look that's
just one of those you know Christian
fundamentalists now you got a Lommy
fundamentalist that's all that religion
hocus-pocus you know we got science
nowadays you know that's the cool thing
the core training all this religious
stuff you just guys just trying to
restrict us what would you say now the
sad reality is all of these types of
arguments are falling back into the same
trap of the devil's where they try to
come to us as if we are intellectuals
and prideful and we know what semester
and the funny thing is even about
science is that a lot of this TV a lot
of the changes and so science is they
what we understand about this world our
limited human understanding of knowing
and that concept and the discussion of
knowing something is very deep and
beautiful and if somebody studied this
for years they would start to realize
truly there is no perfect way of knowing
our purpose in life except through
revelation and that you know when they
try to disguise for example
intellectualism as a type of you know
freedom go away from your religion it's
free religion is confining him it's
actually enslaving you to your desires
and so religion especially Islam where
allah subhanaw taala is freeing us from
enslavement to this world and so Yolo is
enslaving us to our desires and the
mentality of living for the hereafter
living for accountability it's not only
rational and logical it's also better
for us in every single way in this world
and in the next and it's not enslaving
us to that which is pulling us away and
pulling us down as animals and not as
human beings rather it's pulling us up
as a form of humble servants
towards the Creator where at the mass
ethnic convention we're talking about
Yolo we got some more to talk about on
this topic don't go anywhere
Islamic terrorism misconception Muslims
are terrorists this is by far the
biggest misconception of Islam given
unfairly by stereotyping and the public
image that the media gives has anyone
else noticed how when a specific group
of people attack another group of people
it is labeled as a hate crime
but when a Muslim opens fire on anybody
it is quickly regarded as terrorism many
political dictators and officials or
extremist groups use the name of Islam
as a strategy to garner followers and
attention when many of their practices
go against the true basis of Islam the
media has also portrayed Islam as a cult
or a club where if you join you become a
terrorist and that is now part of your
agenda however all over the world people
practice Islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life there are many
verses in the Quran that go against the
idea of terrorism some of these verses
include fight the way of Allah those
that fight you but do not transgress
limits for God does not love
transgressors
this basically means do not fight except
in self-defense and even in doing so do
not go beyond offense another verse
states if they say peace then you seek
peace
which means do not attack people for no
reason or kill innocent people there is
nowhere in Islam whether it be in the
Koran or the teachings of Muhammad that
promotes the killing of innocent people
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with the Yolo you
only live now we're changing it once
twice
absolutely what do you mean go into this
now a little bit deeper what what do you
mean like they're saying only live once
how are we gonna live twice if we die
yes when all this beautiful thing about
the Day of Resurrection this
resurrection when we talk about it is
that God created us with a purpose and
we have to really start to realize as
human beings that there is a purpose
it's not only what we understand with
our limited senses about this world it's
not you know empiricism it's not
rationalism in its limited sense rather
it's revelation nothing that the Creator
is telling us I believe is erecting once
again and as I created you the first
time I can resurrect you easily and as
the Creator created the heavens in the
earth it's easy to create the human
beings again it's not something that's
irrational it's very logical I actually
makes more sense than anything else and
so when the Creator is telling us that
you'll be resurrected again he's telling
us that you'll be resurrected and you
will be held accountable for what you
did in the previous life now in this
world we have all of these blessings you
know some people have different types of
blessings some people go through
different trials some people are born to
maybe disbelieve in families and so
everybody goes through there's journey
in life and they try to understand what
is the purpose of life this is the
question that's been asked for centuries
by all the philosophers and all the you
know thinkers and all the great
intellectuals and so when we talk about
the resurrection we're talking about the
date when we all return all of mankind
will return we will be held accountable
for all of our deeds
now those who repented for the sins as
soon as they repented sincerely their
sins are forgiven that's the beautiful
thing about Snap is that the door of
repentance and mercy is constantly open
until the day
and so there is no sin that you can
commit no matter how bad it is even if
you disbelieve they God even if you
committed all of the worst sins in this
world anything that you do in this world
as soon as you turn back to the Creator
sincerely and you ask for forgiveness he
forgives you so that on the day of
resurrection you come back to him those
sins are forgiven and so even if they're
recorded in the book of leaves it tells
you I forgave you for these sins and
today you'll enter paradise and so on
that day there are only two places to go
there's only paradise or have fun and so
God created us with his purpose testing
us to worship Him to test us to see who
does good and who does evil and I lost
reparative tells us about this through
the messengers that he sent to mankind
and every messenger came with a message
and the final message which was
preserved is the message of the Quran
the Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah Allah
will send and so unless you count Allah
mentions the bath the resurrection
throughout the Quran in many different
ways as a yeoman Arthur Youngman Mzee
Giavotella Giavotella all these
different names for the day when we all
return so we're all standing there and
every single person will be waiting and
they're worried on that day what will I
say to the Creator I thought Yolo I
thought I was only gonna live once what
will I say whom I going to blame and so
on that day everyone is trying to do
what they're trying to get some good
deeds and get rid of their sins and all
that day there is no currency like the
currency of this life so nobody's gonna
have their dollars nobody you have the
rupees only
nobody's gonna really have any of the
worldly currency no Google goes silver
nothing no palaces no houses no cars
it's all about the deeds so on that day
all the currency is the good deeds and
the bad deeds and those that you
repented for are gone and so on that day
people are trying to run around and get
some good deeds from others their own
family their own friends but on that day
everyone is so afraid and terrified but
the word about themselves I need to get
to paradise I need to get to paradise
lepsy enough see myself myself and so on
that day everyone is
worried and I lost the part that gives
us a beautiful example in the quran when
he mentions the difference between the
good people in the slide and the bad
people the good friends in the bathrooms
when he says laughing la loma Ethan Bob
you will be bowing are doing in love
would tapping the good friends in this
life on that day there will be enemies
to each other on the day of resurrection
we all come back to the Creator we're
all enemies to each other we're all
running away from each other we're
blaming each other for what we did in
the previous life for you know taking
you to the club taking you to list
taking you that taking you straight from
the crater taking your desires so
everyone's blaming each other they're
all running away from each other even
the mother the father the kids except
true Illidan what's ugly except those
who have got consciousness those are a
tough one and so these people were
always thinking ahead these are the real
people who are using their intellect
they're worried what am I gonna say to
God on the day of judgement and you know
they're trying so hard so hard it does
take a lot of faith and honor youth have
to realize this that it takes a lot of
faith a lot of strength a lot of
patience to with whips to withstand the
temptations of letting go of following
your desires I'm just following
intellectualism in a way that's more
scientific than religious and so you
know the reality is that for us
revelation revelation and intellect it's
in harmony with what we have our own
logic and rationalism there all goes
together and so we don't have any
preference of one over the other we have
the revelation from God and we have our
personal intellect that's telling us on
that day we will all come back when we
come back what are we going to say we
either enter paradise or Hellfire and we
won't choose our fate our phase in the
hands of the creator based on what we
did in a previous life so if we live the
life of Yolo if we live the life of
carefree you know parties and
and immorality and whatever it may be on
that day we have no one to blame
ourselves and so the last thing I want
to mention is this that the people who
are entering the Hellfire what they're
saying on that day is well well
Hollywood I'll put another smell on
afternoon so these people what are they
gonna say those people who are going to
the Hellfire because they had this gold
metallic
they're gonna say if only we used to
listen to the warnings to the advice to
the lectures to the reminders to the
good people only we used to listen and
what use our intellects and so intellect
is not what people make it out to be in
our day and age intellect is actually
believing in the creator actually
believing in the Day of Resurrection
which is more rational than anything
else and so on that day these people are
worried and they won't be saying you
know this this punishments unfair nobody
ever says that rather they're
complaining and they're wishing that
they could have done good they could
have believed you will live twice you
will be resurrected what will you say to
God what will you do in paradise
paradise
everything that's in paradise as God
tells us in it is that which no eye has
seen no ear has heard and it has not
been imagined by any human being now a
lot of times I ask people when I talk
about paradise I love the subject of
paradise it's spiritually uplifting it
makes us work for it more it motivates
us so a lot of times I'll ask a [ __ ]
ask me this question what's something
that you know a lot of them a lot of
people enjoying this life any kind of
thing that they do something with a
thrill or a rush what's something that
maybe you enjoyed some people you know
don't tell me like skydiving
some people say parasailing so what's
something maybe you enjoy you know most
of the people they enjoy
most people out there to enjoy just
going out and satisfying their cardinal
desires they like to go to the
nightclubs we like to drink they like to
party this is what people like to do
absolutely it's all about carnal desires
but all of the desires end up being
temporary it never lasts and it's always
followed up accounts some kind of regret
that's the Yolo mentality it's followed
up by a terrible lifestyle and so
ultimately those people went to paradise
they're happy that they enter paradise
and they don't regret a single second of
that you only live twice mentality they
don't regret it they're actually happy
so they call up and they say to the
people of the how fired them you did
what your Lord promised it turned out to
be true and their Lord's here doesn't
just mean what they worship but it
includes their desires they Yolo
mentality did it turn out to be true did
you end up just dying and ceasing to
exist and so the people to help are
wishing at that point to go back and
wishing to fulfill the purpose wishing
to enter paradise and wishing to really
fulfill that you will live twice you
will be resurrected because ultimately
if if the devil's pull you away from
that belief then they got you they have
won over either have victory over you as
soon as they make it this believe that
you'll be resurrected you're in loss as
soon as you realize that you have a
resurrection and you have a purpose then
you start to go back to the Creator and
your sins are forgiven and it's easy to
get to paradise as long as long as you
return it to the Creator and we ask the
most amount Allah to make us from
amongst those people I mean thank you so
much exactly anyway yeah not a sequel
thank you so much and there you have it
now you've figured it out Yolo you only
live once but we got you to understand
that it's not once you live you live
twice and if you're about to get pimped
by the biggest pimp shakedown now you
know when that man is trying to have you
lose your chastity and he's like come on
honey you only live once no no you
understand you live twice you're gonna
be accountable because it makes sense if
you're just going to run through this
life and do whatever you want
died and that's it you become dust you
fall asleep and that's oh no you're
gonna be brought back to account on the
day of judgment and every Messenger of
God call people to worship the Creator
not the creation and they warn people
about that ultimate day the day of
judgement will all be accountable for
what we did in this light because his
life is a test so pass the test
by staying away from following the
biggest pimp Shaitaan and pass the test
by obeying your Creator the one who
loves you the one you're gonna return
back to and we'll see you next time if
you haven't subscribed subscribe to the
D show every week new show we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
please subscribe to the diva
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below